[Music]
so much for coming to the AI huddle if
you don't know what AI huddle is it's
Google clouds open collaborative and
developer first forum with Google AI
expertise and our whole goal is to
connect Google AI expertise with
developers and customers who are running
their AI workloads preferably on on GCP
and the goal is to have conversations
with you around AI what problems you're
trying to solve and basically learn more
from your experiences and and have a
dialogue have an exchange of ideas and
thoughts so with that I will actually
let me do a quick intro of speaker for
tonight
okay I got I got to pitch okay cool um
so speaker for tonight is Johan who's an
engineer in Google Flowery I Johan let
me take out Johan is a developer program
engineer in cloudy eyes since 2017 and
previously he worked as a machine
learning engineer and full-stack
engineered multiple startups so with
that I will hand over to you han who's
gonna do a deep dive and tensorflow
topic thank you and welcome I would like
to talk to you a little bit today about
how to use tensor flow in Tucker it's
not a new topic and I suspect many of
you might already be doing this for your
for your work flow if that's the case
there might still be one or two things
that's interesting for you to hear about
today and I mean it's really clear that
I'm really talking about how to how to
run machine learning workflows more
[Music]
efficiently in a sense slightly
different from from the user when people
talking about your machine any workflow
reduced efficiency and we talking about
your own development cycles I'll share a
few personal stories in my in my
previous learning work and and how that
impacted me and how I wish I had to use
darker with a better habit and I'll
probably save me a whole lot of time
just in case maybe some of you have not
used Tucker before me you heard about it
but we haven't even gotten into it just
yet
Tucker's read about dependencies and in
one word just dependencies and that's
that's a way for you to declare and pin
dependencies in a really really nice way
how does that have to do with tensor
flow or or machine learning workload in
general I would like to to sell you this
this vision when I think about a project
that's been down there are just three
components I usually think about one is
the developer that's you who is usually
writing a code that's the code in in one
of the corner of triangle when I
couldn't just run in a vacuum but rather
he runs on some kind of infrastructure
there's some environment that supports
the code that's that can be run in that
environment Internet is being set up by
you again the developer and so that's
triangle here now if you are a single
developer on one person team as yourself
working on a single project a single
code base in an always consistent
environment say your laptop then
probably you don't need docker to be
completely honest with you but any
moment if any of these three corners I
guess of the triangle changes docker
might help you in some ways that's
that's sort of the pitch I have tonight
so you can imagine what how can the
developer cannot change well you might
need to share your project with someone
else on the team if you're working on
multiple person he maybe need hand it
off to your engineer if you are in the
role of a data scientist all the code
you might be working on multiple project
at the same time you might be
maintaining and in fact improving more
than one machine running based services
in your production environment at the
same time environment you might be doing
experimentation on your laptop in
in notebooks or some other kind of
configuration and you do want to move it
to the cloud somewhere for serving or
for for larger scale training and so
that is when you have changed the
environment
angle of a triangle and so whenever any
of these changes you might be in a
situation of dependency inconsistency
and so that's when doctor might help you
I do want to point out that Parker is an
only solution for any of these problems
right there are other ways to deal with
this for example normally for for users
who do need to work on for developers we
need to work on multiple projects in the
same environment be local and your local
machine you see people would go with
virtual environment same height down and
most programming languages nowadays have
some form of dependency management
stools for you so so that is sort of
handled and environment as well there
you know many different ways to to
migrate from one environment to another
without all kind of headache that I hope
to take a little bit about tonight but
the awkward happens to be a sufficiently
flexible and powerful tool that handles
all these in a consistent way and so the
the kind of good habit I'm hoping to
promote in this setting is that with a
fairly small amount of overhead when you
set up a fracturing and when you work on
a project you'll be able to remove some
of this these obstacles later on if you
first see that they'll be a point in
time when I need heads of Penny's
project off to someone else or even just
start collaborating with someone else or
if you see that at some point you want
to you know smoothly switch between
different projects or move to different
environments you might consider start
out with sort of good habit and this is
really general about software different
software development projects and not
specific about machine learning workload
but I want to say that a lot of times
machine learning workloads
have have this hidden dependencies that
people don't talk enough about in my
opinion so in my own example I had a
previous team I had worked on machine
learning project back to back back then
we used psyche learn and that he
provided my model so great and then when
I move on to the next project I thought
I will
upgrading my cycle and version and to
use a new feature which which I need it
for for next project No
so saves me a lot of time only when I
deployed that I realized I was breaking
the previous project because the
previous project could not be loaded
into a newer version of psyche learned
and I don't know if it happened to you
for tensorflow I had the exact same
issue as well I had old checkpoint
trained with older version tensorflow it
just does not load for me anymore with a
newer version and so you can imagine if
you have scientists working in this
situation you might have deployed the
whole model in some way already and the
requirement has changed or the needs has
arisin so that you need to improve that
model you would like to load the old
checkpoints whenever we do all the
experiments it doesn't work anymore
because you've uploaded so you have
updated your tensorflow version so then
that can be I can be really subtle
because these things are really hard to
pin down there are times people go with
keep requirement files and say this is
list of packages that that's needed and
that's that's what we did before a
previous team only when we realize that
we're using a single requirement file
for the a single monophonic monolithic
code base and that's causing prom for
ares everyone who's using the same code
base because i'll be saying hey guys I
need update this particular cycle
inversion to her a fancier version
because I needed and oppress everyone
else to work because they can't use it
and that particular case happened
because cyclin was making very
significant change they move a bunch of
code from pipe down to into into Java
back-end and so that caused a whole of
issues because some interface suddenly
disappeared we do hope that similar
things would not happen to you but if he
does you'll be allowed a long headache
and the end result was something like I
had to spend the whole month trying to
to figure out what's the update path for
the whole code base so that no project
will break I can still use a new feature
I want all models who can still be
deployed to production a lot of problem
and so these are the benefits of docker
exactly corresponding to those three
color changes I was talking about for
consistency if you want to run code in
the exact same environment talker helps
to do that for isolation if you want to
work between different projects with
very quick switch yes virtual
environment is super fast too
in terms of switching projects Parker
can do that as well
collaboration is really the bigger piece
here impact collaboration I mean a
little bit more than code level
collaboration a lot of times you do need
a hand off a whole deployable project a
bundle of some sort to to your engineer
and then you deploy that to somewhere on
your infrastructure and doctor makes
this much much more seamless because the
environment is first of all declared in
understandable way that's very important
and making making the results much more
reproducible so I want to just for for
the benefit of those who might not have
been using docker for a while I have a
little bit of mini cheat sheet here she
showed me some comments I'll be using
today for I think you know like in a few
mins out I'll switch into more like a
live demo mode and show you one
particular workflow so illustrating all
these points I was making here so the
piece of darker there's these two things
that are often confused there's a darker
image and docker container that means
you should think of that as a software
bundle that comes with it the
dependencies already installed in there
and the container is a running instance
of that so the same image could be run
multiple times so you could have one
image being run five times and get five
different containers Oh run in the same
image so think of them as five processes
running the same code and so these are
some basic commands you can pull image
that people have published for ISM here
I'm showing a standard weight was
identify attack image so you see our
sense for Google Cloud the registry it
holds darker images for you so you can
pull it if you have built and published
docker images and you can talk her space
image it's basically so this all the
images you have pulled from from
repositories are mi spent stands for
remove image that's really handy
there'll be a time when you have way too
many diaper images on your laptop
removal
and to run them you basic use the same
syntax also by the way here whenever I
mentioned repository color and tag
that's the same thing as up there so
that whole things you see are that I owe
everything up to : is a entire language
called a repository and after colon is a
tag and so you might be pulling
different things like different versions
and if you have a campaign and that's
running you can kill it again talker a
campaign that is thinking you think
about that running process that runs a
specific piece of binary perhaps that's
it could ask you if you think of it that
way question so far good okay a little
bit more and dr. fire is really the
declaration of how to build image you
are going to go through a really baby
example today and then this next two
things are already interesting I'll make
some more points in in a minute like a
mount value so a darker campaign there
is a process that's running on a host
machine maybe on my laptop so so what
happens is that on the base here that my
laptop has its own operating system and
on top time could be running multiple
darker containers at the same time so
those are called docker containers
processes running on top of the host and
so this will communicate the hosts in
the container themselves and these are
two basic waste waste by mounting a
volume even the share part of your hosts
disk with a process which is extremely
important I'll get one in a minute and
another way is to forward the port so
maybe your campaign is running a service
and by exposing some kind of port on a
container you do want the host to be
able to access that from outside of the
container and that's how you do it you
will just forward a host port number : a
container port number so it's the same
syntax host container ordering with all
the other nice things I could say about
about docker they are a few of you got
jars and so one of the most important
thing I cannot emphasize this enough I
try it I have all capital bold
interleague phone
and in highlight everything into in a
container will be gone again will be
gone I've seen this happening to new
Utica users and experienced users as
well
they've guys who got back her they feel
so at home and they run okay so I've
download stuff install things and you
know drunk old they saved a model
locally and then the exit process all
that is gone so the interesting thing is
that a type of container feels just like
a shell right you can connect to it it's
a process that's how environment feels
like a new computer almost you can do
all kind of things in it even has a file
system in there except that file system
is not persisted the moment you exit the
container everything is gone well unless
unless you were doing things carefully
and connected the running container with
a host in the first place that way
everything you are writing into the disk
in a container does get written to your
host disk that way you not be gone and
so that's really one of the biggest
catches I have wasted hours to recover
work just just because of this after I
learned how to mount disks but I think
about this at this downside of mounting
disks because means your package has
some additional extra dependencies there
like so you were mounting a disk and a
lot of things write code happily but all
our code is no longer in the docker
container so that means this docker
container or image thing cannot be
handed off is any more because now it
has to carry this additional package of
whatever code or data or model that I
have created on the side so that's some
some trade-off we need to think about
normally I recommend doing things with
some of the cloud storage until one if
you can if you foresee that eventually
it's going to be you'll need anyway
start writing things to tooth cloud
somewhere that way you and your team can
easily share that another thing that is
also gone is that you know you connect
into your docker instance and then a
process and you install things it will
also be gone and then you come out run
the code again somehow you don't work
anymore is that complaining about some
package is missing you said wait it's
like an IDE install that before
only you have exited the process and so
so here the actors provides a really
handy way for you to sort of remember to
keep the know
for that is through the mechanism
adapter file so every time we are in a
container install something make sure
you record that in your doctor file that
way you'll never be lost and everyone
anyone can come and reproduce that some
other guys will not really get into
today is networking it's a little tricky
it has to be the port forwarding
business we mentioned before because
docker containers are designed to be
well it's a one of the goals is to be
really secure so we don't really one
containers to be talking to the outside
world very easily for for good reasons
and so sometimes people will have
struggle with networking a little bit if
you are in a situation when you do have
to manage a large number if it just
indicates the multiple containers that
need to talk to each other or outside
world and the hosts that becomes really
complicated complicated graph you might
consider using some frameworks that help
you do that such as kubernetes that's
some other articles out there too and
credentials another issue as well on
your laptop usually just happily connect
to any kind of service services that you
are authorized to use in the container
it's usually running in a different
identity right remember that's like a
whole new computer I happen to be
running on your host machine you might
know nothing whatsoever about your host
machines credentials or environment veil
variables and things like that so they
are issues there as well but what permit
not get into that today okay in
questions up to this point
yes dr. compost is I don't know what do
you think it is
I am not used up before I heard of good
and bad things about it that's why I say
I don't know does any anyone know what
Parker Campos do for you maybe you could
look it up together there was a nun
question or a comment
there's something like that - yes thank
you
so you did pull from typically public
repositories very much like github and
in fact this is something called docker
hub that has published docker images I
need to download so you can download
individual images from there so for
instance that was just in the suite for
tensorflow session earlier and then they
mention darkus where and then you can
they should go to Apple's TF hub
repository and download the swift swift
Tucker that way you can run things on
your on your local machine that's right
to do something like that yes
yes yes so the question was that how do
you do
like incremental update of optical
images yes when you peel the tapping
image that sure has this constable
layers usually usually you know that the
attacker the software attacker itself
handles that for you in saying that it
caches right you're building an image
which really means you start somewhere a
starting point and then start adding
dependencies to it was you your project
needs and eventually adding your code
that has to be executed on top of all
that dependency you're not really
downloading everything every single time
what cannot see that in a bit
so parts that have been downloaded once
will be cached on your system somewhere
and then next time when you build on top
of that you'll not be redownload it
again okay but that's so handled for you
automatically
yes for a for docker or oh inside of
docker I think for a lot of times so I
think yes if you are in your saying
using software in the docker image does
has license
mmhmm yeah I think at least if you
publish things done like a docker hub
you can you have an opportunity to put
in your license there so to specify to
place by that
okay so the kind of workflow I want to
really quickly show today is that how
would I go from experimenting locally
and develop a simple machine learning
model or workflow rather and you see I
was trying to do things carefully on the
local level or the even locally I don't
just run on my host machine but rather I
already do inside the docker container
environment so the later I can literally
lift up this whole docker in the move
somewhere else exact same reason will be
repeated just remember that to say my
work in a volume and then I will try to
try to show you how to build a really
simple minimal docker image and if we
have time I suspect we might run out
when I show how to deploy this this
container before this images container
somewhere to do training okay let me
exit here on the slide okay so my
starting point is that I need start with
something they start with a docker image
that has some stuff that I already need
so I'm just going to use the example I
mentioned before so Google cloud already
published some of this so I'm going to
run a local container workflow I'm just
going to take this because that already
has notebook installed for me so I can
run notebook experiments which I feel
more comfortable and a bunch of stuff
skip over and here's a key point here
how do I know what kind of Parker images
are out there that I can't download
here's one place where I can actually
get a list of one particular repository
and see what kind of images this
particular repository tree has included
so I'm going to just run that and it
lists a bunch of them right so I see
some titled docker images I see some are
images as the tense of
images and compiled in different flavors
and so those are packaged environments I
can is it visible maybe they make me
look bigger let's help okay so I can
just doctor put one of those I'm going
to pull the 2.0 CPU image today so I'm
gonna copy this this identifier here and
sometimes you can add : with the tag
there if you know which text you are I'm
just gonna pull the latest so in this
case I'll be running dr. pol and exactly
that identifier there and it's going to
to use a default tag ladies thing says
it's done well and let me be honest with
you this normally takes a while because
that image is such a six gigabyte in
size so it takes some time for the first
time you run it but subsequent runs will
not require to redownload that again so
you know this saves a copy of that and
as I can also run one who commander was
Tucker images and you'll see a bunch
because I have been playing with this
before but at least we do see that it
shows up somewhere right here this one
here so that's one that I already pulled
three weeks ago and it's in size is a
scary six gigabytes and when I look at
this list of images I was kind of
worried right well I have a whole bunch
of images each one of them reads just 60
gigabytes so I guess something like a 6
x 20 of a bunch but that's not the case
although so in the visual images at 60
gigabytes but they do share the cache
layer and so if they all come from the
same base image that base image is no
longer repeated in different images all
right so our handles are for you really
nicely ok so I have this what do I do
I'm gonna follow instruction here and
say here's the way to run it and
actually run one of image here here on
documentation shows 113 am I gonna run
I'm gonna run 120 2.0 and I'm going to
mount the volume as well so let me copy
this and then modify it so I don't want
to run this this command but instead of
113 I'm going to run to oh and I want to
I do one to forward the port if you see
the adat port that's the default port
for Jupiter lap and I want the amount of
all you i'm not going to mount this path
local i'm going to mount it as i'm to
the mount I'm on my current directory
and the man way around me I am okay I'm
gonna run it and by the way you also see
Oh image not found did I maybe not have
the right
gonna change the name on me so I'm gonna
run now again copying this to make sure
I don't
maybe type it on there okay now I just
be some hash which is of no use and
somehow I'm returned back to my share I
can do things so now here again what
happens that because we had a dash D in
there is in a detached mode so or taemin
so the image will try to run and if ax
is accessed by this case it that's not
exit because the way image this image is
built it just turns on the server that
sound 8080 because the port forwarding
I now can access that's that service
that the two-bit elapsed or server
that's a to run inside the container
through my host which means my browser
can just access that and this mountain
here means it connects whatever
directory I am with the home directory
inside attacker so let's do some
experiments and I have a few a couple
files here I'm gonna make a fake file
I'm making a new file here called delete
me in here and I'm going to connect to
my Jupiter lab localhost 8080 and there
it is and on the left hand side I see
the exact wrist exact same three file
story showing up right here including
the one I just made delete me and so to
just prove to you that these are really
connected so just to make sure that's
also good happy to have to make sure
that don't we lose code here and we'll
come outside here remember this shell
window here in terminal window here is a
host environment I'm not in Parker there
I'm not in that container a right hand
side the Jupiter lab I'm instead of
shocker so it's another machine that's
running in here I'm gonna I'm gonna
remove delete me because it says that so
I'm gonna come back here and then
refresh and it's gone again okay and so
this really validates that these two
volumes are connected one unhoused which
I know it's persisted and the other one
on the talker container that would have
been gone if I were to AXI the process
but because we've mounted volume that's
okay
and right now I'm gonna simulate develop
maybe developing an experimentation for
a model I'm going to just clone I'm
going to go in home first so I see the
same file so this is the home in the
inside of docker container now there's
another machine that shared the disks
and I'm going to just clone this repo I
this stencil for examples that contains
a lot of community goodies in here
so I'm gonna get from that
okay should've done a shadow clone but
it's okay okay we got it so now I cannot
think again
if you still don't believe me I'll come
outside here oh it's not on and I'm
going to twist files now I see the
directory examples now has been cloned
also onto my my my host that's my my
laptop here okay and this one particular
notebook I would like to experiment with
so let me say let me just copy it out
sorry
copy example now let me try to make the
speaker see if that's more visible there
I'm going to copy one of the files out
so I can work with that I always go so
deep into inside of the repo so
community I don't have English I'll take
this auto-encoder notebook and I'll copy
it outside of course he shows up by the
way almost right away
I opened Python three notebook with it
and so so I get I get this code here now
again it's running not on mine well
technically yes is running on my machine
vices Ronnie run run the inside of
environment that's completely contained
in a container something to run all to
make sure that everything works question
three is point by the way may other ways
to access access as question is that how
so the talker brought the talker
contained there what are the ways I can
access I can do it in the browser
because I have exposed
I have run I'm running a Jupiter service
on the docker container and that has
been forwarded to my hosts there other
ways to do that as well from my terminal
window I can actually SSH into it as
well so SSH not really except rather
just I could just connect to it directly
you can that's what I can do so for
example you can see a little bit here
here there is the shale that's running
on the tack container you can do it from
terminal directly as well so you can you
know if you know what is already
installed on the back of container you
can do whatever you need on it yes yes I
think so
I think well what do you mean
mmm-hmm it has approached GPU right yeah
yes but but there is some work so tell
me about shaving other kind of resources
right mounting a volume is sharing the
disk that's a file system with without
container and other resources can be a
little romantic
I think GPU yes is something that I'm
sure is a solved problem because I know
that kubernetes can do that
thank you also the other cal resources
you might want to share that's also very
pragmatic for example you might try to
share the microphone of your host
without a container that can be very
hard to do so but I mean there's way
there's a path forward to be sure other
questions or comments yes
you mean the one on the right the one on
the left has not changed the one that
left has that change because I was
running in a detached mode so that I
could run come here let me go back here
for a bit so he was saying run it and
then let me go back to my own shell
right so it has not changed
I'm still in my own TF in Tucker she'll
still my host machine right the files
are connected through this this bound
mount sorry the dash V commend this dash
V here says right now this directory I'm
in where I run back around command I
want this directory to be shared with
the home directory
is that it and so it's like to do
process um I have a shared memory of
sorts that's right exactly exactly so
that now everything I do inside the
container will be persisted on my host
disk
if it's a question that if you if I used
a data container and sharing the same
volume that still works because that sum
goes through the hosts
probably not recommended now so unless
you you're you know fully in control of
all different containers are doing with
that with amount but yes it does work
right and you can you can mount this
exact same directory on my my host with
something else with another container
that's right and so that would be
physically still the same disk but then
the containers remember they are
religious processes they can access
those at the same time still except when
you're in some container they look like
some local directory that's right that's
right so that's why it's so important
that's why so things will not be gone
the exact yeah that depends on what
you're trying to do with the things
right I mean because then you start in a
situation where you might have race
conditions or you know new thing about
when you lock this file so that you know
these containers accessing you what if
the other container is trying to do
something about it things like that
but yes in priests well you can do that
but then you think about coordinating
this as a man you feel full control of
what the containers are really doing no
problem if you're not sure where right
you might have something let's say
running training and writing output
checkpoints two to one to two a disk and
I have another process to in evaluation
for example something like that
nice totally makes sense because you're
not you and I have like raised right
conditions yes
collapse when you say collab do you mean
like this collab this collab depends on
your use case I think so in this case I
think the collab instances are gone
after certain amount of time so you need
to need to somehow put things in
different places can be a little harder
to install dependencies for example like
here it comes with specific version
tensorflow that you may or may not want
to use for your project things like that
so different limitations Oh in that case
you can write that's all you're saying
right okay as opposed to the round
handle provided by this thank you other
questions or comment ok so where we were
was that I also Ronnie's also encoded
notebook which I did click run all so
just scroll down and see okay there's a
rain seem okay and they scroll all the
way all the way down to the bottom I do
see some outputs okay you did run
through training for 20 bucks and show
the nice graph here and it's also in
whole decoder so you try to produce
reconstructed images of these endless
digits so great okay okay now right I'm
gonna pretend that I work on this coding
and now it's time to hand it off to
someone what do I do
I'm issued to redistrict here and try to
make this sanctuary a Python script
that's roundabout I don't want to keep
the notebook as a source because ease
experiment with but I don't want to
manually copy code out so why would use
this tool called arm and be comfort now
many of you might have used in this case
um I think I don't want to want to be a
little careful here so when I'm
experimenting I'm going to run not 20
parts because could take a while so I'm
gonna run this one epoch let's say just
when I experiment and then in a graph
I'm gonna show maybe
okay but then what I'm doing this I'm
kind of getting concerned because this
is like a temporary change I'm not going
to to cubillas Tweety Parks as hard
qualities I'm going to come back up here
and try to introduce a parameter here
I'm going to go all the way up here
right below the from future importantly
that must be the first thing I'm going
to try to make this into into a into
argument that can be passed into not a
notebook but rather the Python script
that I'm going to create with notebook
comfort so I'm gonna do something like
this in two hours and now have some like
this and that and I want to I want to
just just introduced a epochs parameter
that I can change so I hope they'll have
some like I have something like optional
EEP hogs and with type of end with a
default of c2 okay
and so once I have this and after of
course I want to really parse arcs
I don't remember if it's no marks or
maybe I run it and then rely on normal
underscore arcs okay
in the I'm gonna parse that so now these
arcs variable holds epochs the list
right so they've run this just double
check arcs will be this namespace that
has this thing called epochs that's tool
and they take a pass in different
numbers in the parameter so I'm gonna go
down here to change those things now I'm
not really interesting training to
epochs until I mean once I'm out of the
enemy once I'm out of the you know local
experimentation mode I'm going to remove
our so I'm gonna take our X epochs
okay and replace the other two as well
arcs okay okay so that was okay and I'm
going to try and run this after I do
know become notebook convert and come
out here clear and see I have copied a
copy of the notebook out there and I
really don't want don't like to keep two
separate sources and so I'm going to
call this ipython in B convert and I
need to specify what kind of output it
is there it does a lot of interesting
things you can turn into a markdown
getting into HTML ji-sung is I think the
basic format so I'm gonna turn it into
Python of which file autoencoder at that
notebook okay write something Raisa is
writing a number of bytes to all going
towards the dot pi and I see the file
showing up here right now it's showing
up here okay and so now I can run it I'm
going to just run Python 3 autoencoder
dot pi and I can pass in an epoch
parameter name saying it's French and
remember my default values was to I'm
gonna train like 40 parks right now and
now it basically runs in some ways once
they're at a time but but there's a
little bit gotcha here if you have not
used a notebook convert before
if you use the magical command magic
commands inside of the cells it does not
get converted and so does not run okay
oh my bad
because arcs actually start let me go
back and fix that because I used parse
known arguments here and then notice
that this arc ski is really a tuple of
things one thing is the parameter I
really want to pass in the other thing
is this thing that notebook just carries
along with it that's also part of why I
had to use parts known arcs so I'm just
gonna ignore the second part of it I run
this again rx not just to okay I'm gonna
run the same come in again convert it so
actually me meat cleaver yeah I'm going
to run the convert which again takes the
current state of the notebook making
into a Python script and I'm gonna run
it and Python 3 photo encoded up high it
will be after the conversion and then
passing he passed for oh and sorry if my
screen turns yellow and the night shifts
coming out
okay so nice running and this has a
little bit noisier print out here and is
running first epoch second epoch and so
on okay okay so that's great so now I
have a Python script that I can suppose
you run wherever I want
okay not quite right I do know that this
Python script runs really well in this
starker container that's what the mental
model here I have the host somewhere I
have a bunch of other machines I might
be able to use but I really don't know
if this script runs anywhere except for
this particular container I know that it
runs well here it trains through for me
it has a little bit easier with showing
images because I mean in in shell okay
there's not a problem here
it also does not save the model which I
neglected to do so
it's got threes again I had an encoder
decoder I want to save the model so
where was a training loop here's a
training loop I don't want that I did
end of training right after the for loop
I'm going to save the model so I have
the model save save the model for maybe
say from that it's not here if I'm going
to say that it has a flaw safety model
format okay as opposed to the h5 format
okay so I have this and then I would say
there's a little cut right here if I if
I just run this it will you complain I
cannot save me a major show you I'm
running this notebook here and I try to
say if I just try to run the training
loop is gonna say I'm missing some stuff
because they turns out to save that
tensorflow save save the model format
which is much better sorry which is
really good in a way that it's much more
portable you can movie to other it's a
most self contained so you can you can
deploy that for prediction more easily
but it's complaining now it says it
doesn't know
it doesn't know it's saying I should
call some like this call steady inputs
because to say that enough for me it
needs to know what input shape is
luckily it's not to difficulty the error
message here is really helpful it tells
me as you call set input inputs I'm
doing the pass in the whole the whole
input I think that's called X train and
I run this again again only to epochs
the default value here then you're safe
it was safe I'm a saved save the model
from that the safe model for me and it's
gonna show up on the left side here
refresh
I see saves for save the model directory
and again because we've mounted a volume
and so that exists outside now so I come
back out again that's in my host machine
on my Mac now I look at this I see the
saved model directory and as it was
inside of it it has SS he has saved
model maybe just do this so he has the
variables in SS already saved for me
again even if even if the training
process was running not on my on my
laptop directly but rather inside this
container and they could share that okay
but let's see what happens if out if I
were to try to run the same coming
outside right so I also have I also have
the converted notebook commerce' Python
script right outside here what if I were
to run it I can do Python 3 auto-encoder
that PI he's gonna fail right away
because I don't have any of the
appendices that was installed in a
container right so this is literally the
same script because I'm the shared
volume but running on different machines
that's the environment the different
environment or changing the environment
be that was talking about and it has
different output right so in the
container that's a much more secure and
inconsistent environment that now I know
this script here that mean runs if I
hand hand the scripts or someone else
you will not work by either hand them
the script along with the darker
container it will work for them ok
question so far yes
I would think so so um the question is
like maybe which is a shared directory
yes so in some case if you do have the
your team has infrastructure set up so
that you can have a six year to drive or
something like that and that worked
pretty well I had one of my previous
teams we did have we have everything
hosted in the cloud and so that way
everything would be already shared by
default but that has other kind of
issues because race condition again so
our versioning right other questions or
comments yes
Oh in this case I are you safe and now
safe weights because I was saving as is
that question like you save weight
suppose in this case I just used safe
but I specified that the format to be to
be tested to be tensorflow so that like
already has variables in it like this
file here
predefined wait no for this notebook I
think he just randomizes the initial
weights and it's only meant right but
but then here is safe that the waste
after training right we could another
way so this safe the model directory is
really nice this this this whole tree
here if you and this whole thing off you
can really deploy that and and other
people be able to be able to surf the
model very easily but you are not just
easy to pick it up in the continual
experiments that's sort of the gotcha
here as well so you know it's very
self-contained it has the structure of
your graph and that's the save the model
to PB and he has the weights the Train
weights but if someone wants to actually
load that in a continue with the
experiment so much paragraph in some way
that's a little bit trickier thank you
good question so how about a dataset so
in this case in this particular case
there's one step here where it downloads
data set where do I have it I think this
amnesty in this case right so little can
see it as well so this is part way
downloads they have said it just so
happens that the downloaded data set
leaves on the container but not in a
home folder but somewhere in like a
temporary directory so it will be gone
once they turn off the container okay
and so so this is a small thing that in
the keep in mind if you mount value only
the value must be mounted all to share
otherwise not yes thank you so if I want
to load the model and train for 30 box
beyond two or beyond for I would not be
able to do it with this format is that
right you can't do it but that's that's
why we actually as you change allow the
epochs parameter to be passing from
outside so you can either change that
but right now it looks like I can run it
on my hosts rice is what you're meant no
so I want to trade further epochs on it
to continue from where I have trained it
already
oh we save the model I think you will
have some trouble with that it's doable
just a little bit more work and so in
that case you might want to just save
that as a check point okay there is much
easier to reload it thank you if you
want to continue the experiment
he also saves more than just the weights
but somehow interface is set up so it's
easier to easier to reload back into
tensorflow
it does safe then we're not training
data for sure it does save the weights
and the model our architecture so the
graph itself as well by using slightly
different format so it should usually
think of this safe the model format is
sort of an icy realized format so that's
you know transportable to other places
but for a checkpoint you you still need
to rule we get the stuff it even
purposes so checkpoints usually it's
like the purpose is to resume training
and so you do need a copy of your your
code where yes if you say things up so
I'm a little concerned about about about
saying that is the wrong time status of
that it's not everything now so in some
cases only settings up some of the
layers might lose their parameters and
things like a batch norms it carries
some of the hidden parameters normally
you will keep those as well
but yes it's sort of like in the middle
training was a state right now so that
we can continue later on and save the
mod is more of or I'm done with training
I want to save a copy that I can give it
someone else to serve and that's good
for that purpose because much faster
then reloading from checkpoint and the
serve is very slow
so they have different purposes okay
and the question comments I do want to
have a despite more means of your time
or tweat we go on your 8 o'clock or 8:30
8:30 yeah good thank you
so we go anymore I don't want to show
you the dockerfile at least right so
we've done all this work what for
exactly right unless I it's good a point
when we have a package that I can tell
you someone okay so so this great know
what I have something that I can run but
only in this specific campaign
and there's also separate right I have
this container I happen to be running on
my machine that's great but then this
script here that leaves outside cannot
be run right can already stand alone
because I have cut a connection between
the cold and in the environment I have
the tacker fire already feel so I'm
gonna show you
it's called tiger fire no surprise okay
looks just like this it's not very much
it says I'm starting from something
right that's the base container which
happens to be the container I was
running sorry that's the image just
running this container that serves a
notebook right so that's where all the
experiments was happening in the
notebook the Jupiter server I went
starting from the at that point let me
copy this code here copy this that's no
the real outcome of your hard work that
they indicted runs then these two
together completes the bottom edge of
that's right angle I was talking about
there's a code that works in that
container that environment so now this
is a pretty complete bundle I can handle
anyone now they can just run and I'll
say okay so this is the run comment that
says every time when i run this
container which i'm building on top of
this other base contain and I had before
I literally took the container that
someone else published on the Internet
I downloaded it to some experiments and
created a piece of code that can run on
it and I say okay and I'm gonna be done
on top of that that includes my work now
okay so I'm just gonna building so I
would say Tucker build could have it
here so when I build doctor I would
always use a tag I'm doing whole tag it
like TF world why not and I put a pad
here which means the current directory
because I need to specify the what's the
word a context when you build a talker
so so that means everything in here is
fair game if I and so that that basis
specifies you know these are the files I
might be interested in when I build my
own Tucker image for myself or others to
use so this start here really is the
current directory and you will look for
in a directory a docker file which I
have
in a building and so I'm gonna kind of
build it you will know I hope it doesn't
download a thing no it does not okay so
you see it does not try to download this
whole six gigabyte monster here because
I had done that done that once before
and all this that's why it took such a
small amount of time oh it does this
literally copy this file into it and
specify an entry point so that I get a
run comment okay so now now if I clean
it
I run docker images remember these lists
all the images I have here I just see
the image that's called TF world it's
right here now I just built okay so it
has very little really the Delta between
that and this other Tucker base image
that other people publishes the only
difference is just at one file that we
created and entry point specification
now I can run it now this is an image
that's packaged with the correct
dependencies in place let's run it
so saying docker run TF world and what
happened is that it will load up this
this image my new image which again has
all dependencies because that starts
from something and you'll try to run a
file when I run it this way you will
just run it with the default parameters
so usually you train to epochs because
that's what we said
and now you see that is downloading the
data again so every time I run I was
able to redownload that because that was
not part of my my my attacker file so if
you want you will do something
additional here in the back of fire and
say somehow download training data
perhaps in some way so that you don't
have to always read download it and then
I starting out again the environment is
actually this other thing this can pack
a container that happens to be supported
by my laptop as the base hardware if you
like like 20 bucks and done right so
that exactly what we expected and and
I'm running into into a same no this
show in the picture showing the graphs
issue and what if I want a more parks
here maybe try three so then you should
run the same thing again but now you'll
notice that you have to redownload it
because the previous background command
has exited already is everything else is
gone the downloaded data the saved model
that was in there is also gone because I
did not mount about him right notice
that here when I when s attacker run I
did not mount volume anymore so whatever
is created in the process running that
the container is totally gone now the
nice I'm around a g-strain 3d box
any questions by the way
or comments
okay so you turn three parts and it's
done and I'm not sure why it's not
printing at the error message anymore oh
it does it is up here okay yes
performance I would say just by the way
it works it should be slower because
this additional layer of communication
that's going on but I don't have hard
numbers to say that how much slower it
is I don't I have experienced too much
of slow down myself unless there's a lot
of communication between your container
with your host or your container with
other things otherwise this whole
process is running in itself right so if
you if you can somehow limit a
networking or this guy out I don't I
don't think it should be top to the
gauge yes
right what you already have maybe on
your host machine let's say you could
set things up this way so so a couple
different different options right if you
only have that on your host machine you
can choose to depend on use case perhaps
you can you can you can choose to copy
other stuff in here so and in the text
editor here I could say something like
and copy checkpoint and into also home
directory in that case whatever you have
currently at the time of build in the
image and your host machine will be
moved into it so that's one way to do it
that way it contains a copy for your
starting point another way to do a if
you if this does not serve you need you
might might again mount volume maybe
some time you run it on but then again
mounting value means you'll remember to
carry carry you know that multi-volume
with you if you want to move it
somewhere else so this right over here
and on a point about changing back row
file to be to do more things if you have
other dependencies you may also run here
it's very flexible it's literally like
like you're inside of a shell except you
need to tell it with the special keyword
name every run people install like a
tensor flow data set for example
something like this is now really the
image but you somehow you want to use it
you can just run this only one time the
first time when you view this image you
have to literally run this for you in
that Parker image and then just freeze
that and you'll be there forever
questions
okay um let's see I have a couple
different choices I can go from here let
me show you how to run the same training
somewhere else
now going through all this work there's
a purpose for it the purpose really that
I really don't want to train for 200
bucks on my laptop also not in the
tactical opinion I have it wrong in my
laptop right that's just doesn't make
sense
I prefer when training on some kind of
cloud services and so this is whole
package that you can literally put it
and give it to some cloud service that
will train for you but there's a gutshot
there and everyone should think about
before you really do that in that where
is the output gonna go right like the
locally if I mount things carefully
running running on my host machine or
inside of a container doesn't matter
that much I assume as I remember to
mount the volume right up will be on my
laptop still by restraining in some
machine the whole machine would all be
gone there's somebody in the cloud and
so did remember to to make the changes
properly so let me actually just quickly
adding a couple lines of code to make it
happen I'm going back to this notebook
here remember before adding the
arguments right so to make it more
flexible we we allowed ourselves number
of epochs which well assuming I'm gonna
use some cloud computing source else
train 208 park instead they made another
one I'll say model directory default
tools some just default will just local
right so something like this okay
what's that gonna do is that you will
live it more in any tool now that if I
run this you have the arcs will carry
that as well for me my love the rectory
or what if I pass in around time I mean
past different things right by passing
things I mean some like this remember we
were allowed to pass whatever on a
left-hand side screen now I can I can
pass in additional parameters there see
if I'm just running this Python script
I also remember that what do I wipe
whether when that I want to write a mine
I'm trying to save the mallet there we
go I'm trying to save the model to a
good place
okay so I'm going to do some path join
here and I have arcs model directory and
I'm going to in the model directory have
a saved model directory that contains
the safety model okay as you see see how
this agent make a difference for us I
save I go out here in comfort again
because until I as you convert that
change I made is this only the notebook
that's a single source right so the
whole thing with this note will convert
is that okay it's real quick so it's
done already and so now I know my Python
script outside of the container or my
host also has been changed
I remember that Python script doesn't
run so I have to build again doesn't run
now my hostess is right so even if it
has changed right so it has just changed
a few seconds ago at 7:53 but so it
contains the change which is made of
adding in this order to save it but it
doesn't run until I build it right again
reminding you what happened here was I
my host module simply doesn't have
dependency to run the script but when I
bill the image I can so talk of it again
here world dot-ne Oh oops I think I kept
the install tensorflow TSS you could
hear couple seconds so you also install
taser Proteus a so he install it so if I
had to use that in my training script
now it can be used in this environment
as well and then you successfully build
forget about the red don't worry about
it
it does copy the most recent version of
that now so we can do this now so check
I have one stuff I'm going to run back
around with my talk around for me and
talk around and we we can now
additionally pass in the different model
directory I'm going to call it output
and I run it nice wrong it is updated
script that has this additional ability
or flexibility of saving it's saved
model to somewhere that I specified
called output and I see where it goes it
could become a tuning know what I think
about is
any questions or comments while we're
waiting for this yes
for you and you know the scientist
yourself shouldn't be worried well and
that's my recommendation but if you have
appetite for that you might try to
figure things out okay that's a save
here because I did not put in the
correct price rice is running in still
not not not in the home folder yes
it's possible to do what if every time
when I do a
so just take away all these men your
steps now this time I do things slightly
differently you somewhere in a command
I selected home slash output as the
model directory
now remember home home directories
mounted and so it's coming to my my
local directories I expect to see Oh
I expected to see oh yes I do I do see I
don't see the safety model directory now
no it's not right it's no that's from
before isn't it right I ran it before
I'm not sure why I didn't show up oh I
didn't mind you in a trainee thank you
that's so it's thank you just make sure
everybody goes I saw that this this
mistake I made here is the gotcha number
one gotcha opportunity I still don't
remember myself all the time
I did say that yes after your work is
done save the model to somewhere but
that somewhere is gone now because I
didn't connect that with the host
machine so let's do it again but it's
maybe with a few worried Park so we
don't wait for it one but in the wrong
command as you mounted a mount again the
syntax is that host directory : the
container directory so like this oh
sorry
I also do why not to go into home just
to be sure there
okay any other questions yes
they can look at a coat here just to
clarify that point maybe I took quickly
dinner so so here the output is passed
into us this argument here which is used
as the prefix of the path to write
output - okay so you strain one epoch as
we specified and now I see this directly
called output that has the thing that's
just created right so it has inside of
it there's only one directory called
save the model because that's what what
I told you to do I had whatever you were
given the model directory create another
level call saved model and that's the
save the model bundle there okay so it
looks like this now again okay now why
we're going through this once again
backtracking the reason why we're adding
this additional power to the Python
script is that so I can save it wherever
I want now now imagine if I had access
to some cloud computing resources I can
just say round this container for me
with whatever resources you have but
write output to a you know like some
cloud storage solution but if we can do
that so I don't want to show that real
quick maybe it's five more minutes and
we can go into just more general Q&A
it's that I don't need to push this
image here right so once again darker
images all these images are things that
exist on my local machine only in
particular this thing here this this
package here that now now a can be run
wherever that can run docker B accepts
epochs parameters I can specify a large
number a path if I wanted to and see it
also accepts additional model directory
parameter so I can I can save the output
to somewhere else so let's say you try
to push that I'm going to use Google and
I platforms
training but only because I have access
to that and I have a cheat sheet here
for myself I remember the command of how
to push an image okay here's what I have
to do - push okay
a little trick here I need to rebuild it
with a different hack I think different
services - things differently you use
docker hub I think you need to use their
tooling to push and then you specify
attack different ways I'm going to I'm
going to review the same image and call
it a I think so I don't want even darker
because why not I'm gonna build it
I'm in the wrong directories you see
what what's happening here is that it's
trying to look for a file called Packer
file in where I am right now but
remember I just changed the writer into
the output directory who it doesn't have
it it has only save money again built
with this and iced it doesn't be a new
tag luckily it's very quick again only
because literally I'm just renaming it
okay now I have this this new image you
here just double-check that images I see
it somewhere up here this is a tag now
I'm looking for something that's that's
created just seconds ago
so let me change it
I don't want to see that silliness I
just created
okay so sick successor attacked dr.
images do I see it I see this one now Oh
see I was a bit worried when you said a
minutes ago why do you say Amy disco
because nothing has changed in the past
eight minutes right so doctor handles
that for you as well if any of the files
I'll copy into the image has changed it
will rebuild that for you if nothing has
changed it would just use the cache so
you don't have to think about Oh have I
just always run it you would get the
most the current state of things if Dan
Tien changes you're not wasting time
wasting your time doing work either and
then I have secret homage sheet here
also the push command this bunch of
other stuff just so that I can access
that but feel free to ignore that I need
to authenticate
I don't have keyfile let's see if that
works still you may work just is the
same and I'm gonna push I'm going to run
docker push this image here to somewhere
see that done is tagged here the tag I
use which looks really long right before
I should call it here world super is
remember why do I need this long and
messy juicy other i/o and so on because
it gets parsed and so g-cloud command
knows that knows where to put that thing
into just to be sure let me push the one
that says one known let me push the same
one just so you don't take too long okay
so it's gonna push oh and I'm afraid you
could take some time because I also did
install sorry did install tensorflow
datasets just now which is additional
into upload okay pushed you see how this
bunch of stuff here layer exists one of
those layers those are the base layer
the Cystic abides of stuff which I
previously had pushed before so it's
it's gonna get reproached because
there's no need for that attackers
internal it's using these hashes to
identify individual the year so he knows
oh I see this hatch here let me look for
in all the past push the layers before
if something already existed there's no
need to Dec a just booting from there
okay so it's pushed by where is it is
pushed to this directory here it's on
Google I'm in a council now for TCP and
I have container registry and for this
project I have a TF in Tucker repository
and it has a few images and then the one
that we just pushed it over here is just
now so it's just pushed ok and so this
is open requires also you think of this
sort of like a docker hub so now if you
have a teammate who manages running of
experiment right well meanwhile you are
exploring and designing experiments
someone else handles running for you you
can just say here it is
now try to run it for me with whatever
infrastructure you have maybe run hybrid
parameter tuning if you want
things like that which you can just you
know create a large number of them and
I'm going to copy this image name here
which is pretty messy right has all the
hash at the end but there's value in
that so the specifies exactly this copy
of the image so that it the result can
really can be reproduced and I'm going
to run it in a I'm gonna paste in here
again this is my cheat sheet I already
have the command already already written
down but we can talk about this a bit so
what I'm trying to do is I'm gonna use
g-cloud command again try to run a
training german air platform because i
don't want to run out i'm a laptop
i'm going to give you a name called
something TF world i must admit the
training job in the certain compute
region i want to turn out computer
resources there and then here's an
interesting flag here master image uri
that kind of ties back to the question
we had before what do you have masters
in and workers you can even have
different images for a whole cluster of
machines if you want but here i'm just
saying i only want one machine that's
wrong son that runs this particular
thing and i'm going to specify my model
directory to be a google cloud storage
location code even darker maybe even
talk of one why not just take world and
then run 3d box i'm gonna run this
command and see what happens i'm going
to run it it's only three parcels not
very long by an imprint in in the real
situation you probably only for 300 or
something
okay so here's command once again oh
it's not formatted correctly and
properly so I'm running I'm submitting a
training job and the only description of
the job is just I don't even upload code
anymore kita I don't return that I'm
just saying
Ronny's container for me with these
parameters can I expect reproducible
results and it says cute
like acute where it's not running my
laptop it's running wherever I stopped
me the job to which is yeah platform
here now you see this job is running
when go in there and look at log so
there's not a whole lot to see people
have seen that many times is this even
already it's gonna be exactly the same
thing because literally all this does
this that is going to try to secure some
time to research this for me and then
run exec that container and because the
whole environment is carried over right
every dependency that we have used in
two different ways my the local to be
the Jupiter lab when I was doing
experimentation as in in certain
environment and then when I was testing
the the scripts outside of here that's
the exact same environment and
furthermore here this online in the
cloud training job that's running yet
again the very same environment there so
I should expect that to happen very soon
any questions I would disagree works no
comments
and if you use kubernetes if you already
maybe you and your team already have the
kubernetes cluster already said that we
have multiple nodes complete resources
for you to use you can deploy this as
well that's again one package that can
can be moved where we want - training
data unless you you do things carefully
as well by the way issue one yes
yeah you can totally do something like
that so the question is somebody we have
really large dataset and you want to
solve part process different parts so
that you parallel perhaps right don't
you don't care if one part processed or
trained first before another you can
also again you don't want to create the
same code for different different
workers jobs there you might this is
something I was try and do I was adding
at me and again another another argument
here I'll say something like they had
the right theory or something now I can
additionally pass in and in that way
when I when I spawn up different
containers I can just pass them
different directory target maybe they
are different directories containing
allowed tazer flow files that is it for
record file sorry things like that then
I can just you know past seen that way
when I create a new container process
again in the exact same environment only
thing I want to change is the process
even portion of the data out even shard
of data I can pass this in okay probably
because of tensorflow world is not
running first but I don't want to show
you that what happens when this does
work is that I expect to see
a right what would we pass in before I
passed in this as a target location to
write the save the model out - and I
think / change the from inductor TF that
was a this is a I think pocket and here
I expect to see a new directly being
created that contains the safety model
when a job completes and exits if you
would just run normally wouldn't take
that long you seen my previous
experiments usually take oh it's your up
to ten minutes before it completes but I
think the actual running takes some time
so what's happening here is that I
specify this this new Tucker identifier
remember this is long and ugly string
here that has this whole hash number
everything so the infrastructure does
have to pull that the thing I just
uploaded somehow so he's pulling that
and I try to run it so but we can just
let it run and then later we'll see what
happens but I think that's about
concludes everything I want to show you
for this evening
why don't we switch to a more of a
chatting Q&A session if you if you like
and you know it's pretty late if you I
thought this is the tend to feel free to
to go tend to them and I'll be here on
to 8:30 if you want to chat with me
thank you I all the time is finished
thank you so look let's finish let's say
should go here and really quickly see
make sure we save the file and now it
does say if it does just created this
thing here and that has the saved model
for me and so again the checkpoint
checkpoint kind of scenario you write
the check points also down to some
storage so that your team can come in
and maybe evaluate maybe figure out how
to deploy maybe continue your
experiments for you
[Music]